I'm putting in the hot seat yeah yes
Queen yes in the city by the way I think
out of anyone that I know you were the
most excited about my Christmas record I
think you started texting me like
literally a year ago you're like pour it
on the street
word on the street there's a Christmas
record call me I was like Kathy calm
down I know I know we're here I know
toward the top of Empire State Building
no when the the Christmas Christmas in
the city cover was released last my mind
this Christmas like how dare you just
reinvent Christmas with a red gown is no
more Christmas it's so beautiful so why
was it so important for you to do this
record you know I had a really awesome
year I got married this year and it was
just like a really wonderful happy time
and I thought the best way to
encapsulate this amazing year would be
to put out a Christmas album which for
me just always reminds me of my favorite
time of year being with my family always
so happy and I wanted to have the album
be about New York which is my hometown a
little the west coast now the album is a
little bit of a love letter to New York
City which is where I always spend the
holidays and it's a pretty big deal to
be lighting the Empire State Leo a
born-and-bred New Yorker and then being
like I shall light the Empire State
Building yeah what does that mean to you
so my incredible
music producer that I worked on this
album with Adam Anders he and I did all
the Glee songs together when we sat down
I said I want to write a song about New
York and I wanted to be this love letter
to the city and talk about all of the
amazing places in New York where you can
you know especially during the holidays
but I'm also gorgeous and we wrote this
song Christmas in New York and to have
that song be the theme song and to play
alongside the lighting of the Empire
State Building as a New Yorker it's so
surreal and just so crazy and being up
here right now I could never like in my
wildest dreams in creating this album
like this is everything and anything I
could have hoped we would have been able
to do every year in December I come home
for the holidays and the minute I see
the Empire State Building all lit up
that's when
I know that I'm home it's Christmas and
I'm with my family I created this album
Christmas in the city as a love letter
to New York and it is such a huge honor
to have a song that I wrote Christmas in
New York to be a part of such an iconic
New York moment of lighting up the
Empire State Building for the holiday
season so this is such a true honor for
me I couldn't be more grateful and thank
you so much for having me thank you
[Music]
so Christmas is the greatest music of
all time which we've already covered is
my favorite how did you pick which songs
so I wanted to pick my most favorite
Christmas song yeah so all of these
songs are my favorite Christmas songs
but I also you know I got to do a lot of
songs on Glee already know we had a few
kiss albums so I wanted to make sure
that I these are all songs that I've
never sang before I think the only one
that's a crossover is oh holy night
other than that these are all songs that
are my personal favorites and ones that
I've never gotten to sing before
ooh I love this and then you just happen
to have the coolest collaboration this
great collabs how did this come to be
I wanted a combination of really good
friends so jonathan groff is one is is
my best friend yes whole world Darren
Criss who I love so much and Cynthia
revos a dear friend but also these are
people who I've worked with before and I
wanted to bring it in a little bit of
that Broadway element to the album as
well and the you know Cynthia is a Tony
Award winner and Jonathan is a Tony
Award nominee and Darren is a Broadway
star and said they all bring in that
Broadway element to the album yeah I
love that you and Jonathan are
essentially like taking over the holiday
set like between Reuben and your red
herd I'm like uh we have a new happiness
around the Christmas you know it's so
crazy because I just did a Macy's Day
Parade like when was this and Jonathan
and I did the parade over 10 years ago
together and I remember people were
screaming in the crowd they were like
who are you and we were like where's
that guy running Vanessa Hudgens
sounds like high school musical time it
was unbelievable sarire surreal moment
where I was on the float the other day
and I was like texting he was like it's
not the same without you but like where
he's at he's so successful and he's just
these careers it's so amazing and I feel
so fortunate and it's so unbelievable
how things come full circle it's
beautiful listen I know you sang at like
5 o'clock this morning on The Today Show
is there any way I can get like one
Christmas line from you right now is the
voice still warm
my favorite lyric okay all time it's
it's in silver bowels when she when they
say it's
Christmas time in the city and any time
I hear that lyric that's how I know like
up it's Christmas time since it was that
lyric of silver bells where I was like
oh I want to make a Christmas album and
I wanted to be I wanted to be about New
York City I love this so much I was with
one of your friends and I got a sister
Becca no I got a special message from
them about you co-hosting ET today in
case you were nervous so I'm gonna
Belaya for you could it here it is Lia
don't hide your light under a bushel get
out there show people out talent I know
you're shy I know you're bashful no one
else is I and I do but you gotta let the
world know what you can do you know what
honey is like I have like chills cuz I
just feel like that was Sue Sylvester
like that was too much but that was also
sick Sylvester just like looking at me
and I just look oh my god let's do it do
you watch Mazal have you want but of
course and I feel like right now we're
all kind of on like a little bit of like
a pressed or like yeah I was just
somewhere with Rachel Brosnahan and and
I was like just fangirling out and you
brought up backup before what I think is
so special about this cast and I know
you're so sick of talking about it but
like the fact that you guys are all
still friends my gosh Glee on
Thanksgiving Day just find myself in a
room we do Thanksgiving episode I really
want to watch the fact it was like in
between courses I was like in a bedroom
just with like my cat family was like
outside and I was watching but it's so
cool that you still like you're still
friends with everybody it's really
unbelievable I mean the thing is is that
no one will ever know what that
experience was like except for the
people that were in the choir room
together
yeah so it's a bond that is
unexplainable that will just bond us for
the rest of our lives
oh my gosh what a segue talking about
forever bond mrs. mrs. a married it's
your first holiday as a mrs. so what
traditions what are you guys you've
known me in all phases of my life right
I know I mean I knew you were only like
a road trip you were where it's like
special or underwear and the holiday
season to bring you love oh yes and
hello right oh this is an inside thing
that Kelty knows about me so I'm very
superstitious on
New Year's yes and I believe the colors
that you wear during New Year's you can
bring in whatever it is that you sort of
like want for the year right and so just
a few years ago I wore a lot of red
underwear I know it's so great so what
are you guys planning to do what are
your new traditions how are you spending
we right now we haven't really got a lot
of like new traditions but this will be
I think our third or fourth year where
we're all together with my mom and dad
we do Christmas you know on the East
Coast we cook we watch movies my mom
makes us wear ugly sweaters
we're in pajamas all day we like will
sit outside by the fire and it's just
like cozy with my mom and dad like
family so nice my husband is a horrible
gift giver what you know is you a good
gift giver and what's the best worst
gift you tell him what you want man
Wow because he was so bad are you like a
teller are you I just yesterday told my
husband what I want for Christmas okay
which I've never done before and he is
such a great gift giver Oh last year for
Christmas he gave me a wedding Survival
Guide which was the cutest thing ever so
he made this beautiful box and it had
like labels and photos and it was all of
my favorite things to help me get
through like the wedding planning stuff
so it was a gift certificate to a
massage it was a membership to this yoga
place that I love a sugar fish which is
this amazing sushi place on the west
coast a sugar fish gifts or take this
was all my favorite things and like time
of me like whatever I needed how cute
they should marry that man I did that's
very good you are very very busy in
addition to Christmas in the city you
have your movies same time next
Christmas yes you are the one
Olivia right hi what are you doing here
[Music]
I'm sorry I I didn't know that he was
coming I didn't know he existed you know
what if you're gonna make a Christmas
movie did you shoot in Hawaii I sure did
I'm like you burned the bikini is this
movie it's it's a Christmas movie in
Hawaii we have we filmed it in August
for the whole month on the North Shore
it was so awesome except every day like
it was very hard me wearing a lot of
makeup and having your hair fully done
and not being able to like dive in the
ocean I'm like the wait I'm confused we
can't swim right now
but it was so gorgeous and the whole
cast was amazing we had way more fun
than we should have and it was awesome I
want to talk about beauty because you
are such a Wednesday wellness guru well
is your lens well as Wednesday I know
what I'm always following like what
you're using and so we love a beauty
trick do you have a beauty trick you can
share with our audience I keep my Jade
roller in my freezer and every morning
like this morning the minute I woke up
it was just Jade roller freezing cold
it's like an ice cube it's not like a
beauty thing that's a great tip more of
like a wellness it's not like a makeup
tip no it's intervention okay it's
perfect a frozen Jade Roller yes a
frozen yeah Michelle I love that so much
[Music]